a police operation gets underway in the
Alamo favela in Rio they happen almost
daily and they're always violent this is
the core a unit the police Special
Forces and thereafter a shipment of
drugs a big shipment in Rio that drug
gangs are ruthless and well-armed the
fire fighter team the security services
and the gangs are intense there are lots
of people living here but that doesn't
do anything to lessen the fighting this
is a housing estate in the middle of the
day anyone on the street simply has to
find safety on their own or risk getting
caught in the crossfire the police are
after a shipment of marijuana from
Paraguay
two armored trucks are sent in to drag
out a lorry officers put down fire as
its pulled away this was a successful
day on board two tons of marijuana worth
about a million dollars the thing is
another is already on the way the level
of violence being seen in the favelas is
what's concerning people the police
operations are continuous and often
deadly but nothing much seems to change
the poorest in society live here and
they are predominantly black they feel
like they are the enemy
in their own country every day this year
more than five people have been killed
in Rio State by the police
most of those killings happen here in
the favelas which are controlled by the
drug gangs question is how much about
the fact that they are shooting and
killing gang members the point is that
so many innocent people are getting
caught up in the crossfire martial arts
students form a line to pay their
respects
Andrea Rios hasn't been to this charity
funded martial arts project in the Alamo
favela for over a month
she isn't from here and knows her
husband there were volunteers helping
deprived kids Jean was coming to teach
jiu-jitsu when he was shot dead by
police in a raid he wasn't armed and he
was crouching there is no investigation
into his killing here there is often
zero
Cassini's Aleta valiant Rajah
naturally the pushback
[Music]
the battle against organized crime or
narco-terrorism as they call it here is
one of the central pillars of the
government of Brazilian President chair
Bolden our oh he has a willing left
tenant in the form of the governor of
Rio we joined a ceremony for new
motorbikes and trucks being assigned to
the police
the governor is adamant that despite
criticism of the police the tactics
unnecessary virginity Sierra Maestra
poses as a choice estamos haciendo Duma
for Mama's blisters that American
Muslims combatant is too short hola
since the criminal edad vivaciousness
Viviani it is men Seldovia do-si-dos
asustor some 80s omitted from ECT the
numbers of people being killed by the
police in Rio's favelas is at record
levels but the gangs are still operating
the no-nonsense tactics are popular
amongst voters who don't live here
innocent people who do take a different
view still ramesses gar news Rio de
Janiero